es posible que a usted oa alguien que
conoce le hayan diagnosticado diabetes
tipo 1 este vídeo le ayudará a
comprender qué es y por qué es
importante mantenerla bajo control
la diabetes tipo 1 es una afección en la
que su páncreas produce poco o nada de
insulina la insulina es una sustancia
química que su cuerpo necesita para
mantener su azúcar en sangre en un nivel
normal los hidratos de carbono son
sustancias que su cuerpo utiliza para
fabricar energía después de comer
alimentos que contienen hidratos de
carbono estos finalmente van a su
intestino delgado en su intestino
delgado el alimento se descompone en
moléculas de azúcar únicas llamadas
glucosa las células de su intestino
delgado absorben los azúcares que pasan
al flujo sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas
detecta la alta cantidad de azúcar en su
sangre
normalmente esto provoca que su páncreas
coloque una sustancia química llamada
insulina en su flujo sanguíneo la
insulina reduce la cantidad de azúcar en
su sangre a un nivel saludable
como lo hace la insulina a medida que la
sangre se mueve a través de su cuerpo la
insulina y el azúcar salen del flujo
sanguíneo y se meten en sus tejidos para
llegar a sus células
la mayoría de las células tienen
estructuras en sus superficies llamadas
receptores de insulina cuando la
insulina fluye por ahí se adhiere al
receptor
la insulina actúa como una llave en una
cerradura para abrir la célula
y permitir que el azúcar pueda ingresar
en su interior
ahora su célula puede usar el azúcar
para fabricar la energía que necesita
para trabajar de manera apropiada y su
nivel de azúcar en sangre cae de regreso
a su rango normal
si tiene diabetes tipo 1 su páncreas
pierde su capacidad de producir
suficiente insulina o algo de insulina
esto puede provocar altos niveles de
azúcar en sangre y otras complicaciones
en la diabetes tipo 1 su sistema
inmunológico ataca a algunas células de
su páncreas por error
como resultado su páncreas produce poco
o nada de insulina
sin insulina el azúcar no puede ingresar
a sus células sin azúcar sus células no
tienen energía
y como el azúcar tiene cerrado el acceso
a las células se acumula un alto nivel
en su flujo sanguíneo esta es una
afección llamada hiperglucemia que puede
llevar a complicaciones serias
si tiene preguntas sobre la diabetes
tipo 1 o cualquier medicamento que le
hayan recetado hable con su médico es
importante que tomen sus medicamentos
como se lo indicó su médico cuéntele
sobre cualquier efecto secundario que
tenga